(upbeat music)
- I have a feeling that
the Italian version
is probably better and
less preserverty tasting.
This is adorable. This is
so adorable. I love it.
- Visually these look
pretty much the same.
- Color, exactly the same.
- One of them smells more...
hazlenut-y.
And I'm guessing that
that's the Italian one.
- My immediate reaction is that this one's
a little nuttier and this one's
a little more chocolate-y.
- This one has more sugar in it.
Which makes me think
it's the American one.
I'm almost positive that
this is the Italian one
'cause the milk tastes
different and it's less sugary.
This is the American one.
(bell ringing)
Italy is just doing
everything better than we are.
(buzzer ringing)
- I think this one's Italian.
I think this one's American.
(buzzer ringing)
(bell ringing)
- I'm gonna say this one's
American. This one's Italian.
(buzzer ringing)
This is like the first
time a non-American version
of something was the sweeter version.
(bell ringing)
- Go to a world market.
Go to a farmer's market.
Go to a black market. I don't care.
Get the Nutella that you need in your life
because this is so different.
And so much better.